[Music]  to our coronavirus coverage  new covid cases are up to 625 across our  state  most of those right here in clark county  statewide eight new deaths have been  reported  the percentage of people becoming fully  vaccinated is inching up we are at  nearly 45 percent of all nevadans being  fully vaccinated christian  well if you received at least one dose  of the coronavirus vaccine you'll be  entered to win  5 million dollars worth of prizes things  like state park permits and fishing  licenses  the grand price is one million dollars  winners will be announced  every thursday starting july 8th through  august 26th  now the program is funded through the  federal government and will be a random  anonymous drawing